vauthier on sent que les tensions
reprennent en tout cas s'ils n'ont
jamais disparu on va démarrer que le don
de basses ces échanges de tirs gauthier
qu'est ce que ça signifie le président
ukrainien évoque effectivement une école
qui aurait été visé c'est le lieu idéal
pour une attaque russe compte tenu de ce
qui a été déjà testé plus ou moins
verbalement par vladimir poutine et qui
s'est rendu compte que tout ce que
pouvait faire l'occident et c'était
c'était la position tactique de
washington s'était de dramatiser et
d'élever le niveau de dramatisation
précisément de cette affaire et la
tactique de moscou c'est peut-être de 10
rebonds une invasion totale de l'ukraine
n'est pas pensable mais pas contre
profité de prétextes adéquat pour se
livrer à une invasion du donbass ça
pourrait être quelque chose
d'intéressant dans le cas de figure qui
nous préoccupe on imagine mal mais il
faut et vous devez évaluer toutes les
possibilités on imagine mal les
ukrainiens qui jusqu'à présent fait
preuve de grand sang froid
provoque et précisément à l'affrontement
sur cette ligne dans le donbass h ans
que moscou est d'ailleurs les
indépendantistes d'une basse ne
souhaitent que cela pour sous pour se
mettre se lancer dans une opération
quelles qu'elles soient de petite ou de
grande envergure on peut estimer par
exemple que les séparatistes d2
république fantoche de lougansk est
bonne yates qui pourrait pourrait se
lancer dans une opération dans laquelle
il se réveille évidemment les martyrs et
vous savez que la martyrologie compte là
bas aussi et à partir de quoi on
pourrait appeler à la rescousse le grand
frère russe donc cette cette bombe ou
c'est cette attaque notamment sur une
école elle a pour but pour les
ukrainiens de démontrer que les autres
agissent de façon particulièrement
cynique ce sont les mots du ministre et
craignant les affaires étrangères mais
cela aussi pour but de montrer le
prétexte que vladimir poutine peu disons
invoquée pour justifier une frappe ou
pour justifier une intervention qui
serait et c'est ça le drame ou au final
elle serait finalement médiane sur
laquelle presque aller on pourrait
presque s'entendre avec l'occident on va
retrouver justement l'univers